that bright shining light from above
we're also co-hosting New Year's Eve of
Miley Cyrus Oh I know that's gonna be
fun we talked about that when she was
one of the guests yeah so we talked
about what we'd wear I said you be you
and I'll be me and we're gonna do some
skids we're going to do some hosting
we're going to do some songs so it
should be fun I'm sure we're going to
wing a whole lot of it which is going to
be the most fun how nice is it for you
seeing all the success that she's had
she's like me you know be true to
yourself it doesn't matter what other
people say if you worry too much about
things you don't get a lot done what is
one of your favorite holiday traditions
at home
well I love to do what every family
loves to do if you are a family you love
to get with family you love to eat your
favorite foods I cook more like Mama
than any of them everybody says because
I still cook with grease and butter and
things that make stuff taste good and my
sisters they try to live a little
healthier but they can still manage to
make you know when I say if you're
cooking Mama's food you got to cook it
like Mom doesn't if you ain't going to
I'm cooking it right yeah we all bring
something to the table but we love
getting together singing and tell
stories and have the kids you know have
the presents and my husband's family and
my family and then I live in Nashville
my big part of my family lives in East
Tennessee so we gotta travel around some
to have Christmas with everybody but
that's half the fun between Christmas
and New Year's we get it all in yeah I
love that would your husband Carl say
that you were on the naughty or nice
list this year uh I think damn I was a
little of both I'm gonna let Santa
decide on that one that's good is coral
on the nice or naughty list
perfect yeah that's why we've lasted so
long we're just naughty enough to be
entertaining and nice enough to make it
last yeah